personne ne peut nous vendre quoi que ce
soit gratuitement et de même nous
produisons gratuitement pastel nous
avons bien livré aux consommateurs
européens nos ressources le gaz ils
l'ont reçu au point qu il n 1 ils nous
ont payé en euros et ensuite ils les
gels c'est aux rosiers et georges est
postale une partie du gaz livré en
europe nous livrons gratuitement de fait
price cp1 des règles claires pour
acheter du gaz naturel russe ils doivent
ouvrir des comptes en roubles dans les
banques russes et c'est avec ses contes
qu'ils pourront payer le gaz
michaud-nerard cuche 10e n'ya ça
commencera à partir de demain le 1er
avril